[Music]
started I had a bed I had an a bad
episode and it kind of broke me down and
low morale is low like La Salle might
might got me a tall boy yeah I need some
sort of support
honestly like I do I feel a little I
feel a little broken I just like feel
like big Butthead I like couldn't
survive but I'm back I've had a few
swigs Tecate to come back I have a
wrench yeah I was thinking about
bringing the shotgun no extra bullets
but shouldn't shotgun shells cuz I have
four slots now yeah
lockpick first-aid spray and gun and gun
bullets yeah in that case so you could
do two things how do you feel yes tell
me
you could go oh I'm sick I'm hurt I'm on
caution so we're looking for the fuse
the machine oil and the that's it
because I have the other one power cord
I have the key I of the cord so we need
the community's oil oil the fuser I
remember correctly is when you put out
the fire you could do that first I was
thinking yeah cuz I got this wrench so I
think what I'm gonna use I'll use that
wrench to put up a fire so I think
that's where I should go well no you use
that to get the fire hose to put out the
fire but you also use the wrench for
something else
okay well
you tell me Oh learn it one so pan over
to the left can either go up through
that door through that maze of cars to
the gas station and that's where the
monomers if memory serves I know the oil
or the fuse is there make sense back
where it was and up yes but you also so
like remember ever there's this I just
did I didn't tell you to do this earlier
because you were needed to say it but
the room where those three zombies
busted out of I think that's the one
where the statue is oh those [ __ ]
right here there were plants in there
though I saw him yeah but you also need
to go that's like the central piece of
this puzzle but to get all this stuff
before you go back to the trolley so all
right back up here I would just yeah go
shock on those zombies in the head shock
on the zombies in the head go through go
through maze go together bring I know
you need the crank for the fuse or the
machine oh my like a member which and
since you of the space just bring it
okay
you got it yeah I do have the space and
I love that I'm so glad I got more space
like it just like means the world to me
that I like don't have to go back and
forth through this [ __ ] I wonder if
you could even bring there we go
wait on I think kind of health you ever
know I'm on caution but there's plants
in the zombie room
I can remember if you need the lockpick
and I feel like I don't wanna take up
space with a lockpick it's been useful
thus far if we look at the map are you
sure you check this room this why is it
red still this is red
oh the safe room I don't I can look at
it again okay this is red which makes me
think I'm gonna need a lockpick okay so
I well see you get in there yeah I can
look into Joni go set yet I think he
gives you something that helps with that
knowledge puzzle remember his his name
the mayor's name cuz like that blue
stuff in the box looks like it's
important but bottom the bottom
something at the bottom on those things
here that are you're gonna just go
through there or nevermind all right all
right I'm leaving here we go
please nemesis don't be there you prick
I was kidding I was kidding come on oh
it's nothing mrs. good Oh Juke this guy
I don't like them being there though
because what you have to understand is
I'm gonna need to come back to the safe
room I'll probably be injured and scared
and now I'll have to do zoms remember
this game does a good job and never
making you feel safe so I don't think
you're gonna get high you know what I
have not felt safe check that that body
right next to you right now sure this
guy yeah it since the nemesis isn't here
yeah there you go
health oh that's good that's still there
good scour the rest of this area uh yeah
let's do it
not like every engine see just dead
bodies and blown out cars or general
rule-of-thumb good I don't think you
stopped at that dude on the way okay
nope
a couple signs you got a lock of hair
from the barber shop you burned the hair
oh [ __ ] alright what am i doing juggen
you can group him up it sucks because
they were grouped up before but I think
if I go in a rush I think I can do it
check it you're gonna be you're gonna be
coming back here a lot so it's worth
just killing him I think this is a
central point though chef let's reset it
really yeah what do you if you can group
him up to use a head I thought they were
all gonna walk towards me and they
didn't so hmm I could okay
I could shoot that guy with with regular
with rhaggy rhaggy bulls this will
attract the other ones and then I can
shock on them shotgun okay here we go
oh nice
[ __ ] head I'm feeling way better
about my life right now
you I'm gonna keep my shotgun um you
think that guy's dead with like four
shots doesn't seem right does it
no at least you can get the he's dead
all right sweet sweet sweet oh oh [ __ ]
wait here okay so hold on a second check
your inventory I would like one no I
know you're gonna be coming back here
often so actually okay ooh
so he's gonna give you I don't even know
if you want to do this yeah
a bronze statue of Raccoon City Mayor
Michael Warren is he carrying a gun no
it's a book Oh looks like a gun he's
just like his you know he's just like
chill dude and they're like we'd like to
make a statue in your honor mr. Warren
and he's like here we go make me Haidee
just like me like one of your french
like rest this glock against the jail
yeah here we go all right so what do you
think president yeah he's gonna give you
the book or you can accept it and then
that's what you feel like to the no or
yes I can say no and do it later cuz
then then it takes up an inventory song
you're gonna do this eventually so but I
I could if I'm going to the gas station
I could do that first so my god you do
this and dude you're so inconsistent
just commit you don't have to get I try
think of the order from what I remember
you do
take that bring that bring that bring
that do not do that yet just you're
gonna do it a second the bronze beak you
could just take them those and heal up
now that's what I'm saying I mean close
quarters and the car maze yeah hopefully
I bring you to find not just a high
caution I hate when that happens
damn yes expecting the worst
All Right see you later Dead Boys I'm
super nervous that out of reflex you
might use a shotgun shell you want me
move you want me to change I would
recommend it
give me in close quarters in there I
looked at the name cuz I forgot the name
of those new liquors things they're
drained demos like demos I don't know
and they can poison you okay well I
don't even remember where the blue [ __ ]
is you got a couple in your inventory I
thought all right I hit the Run button
the maps probably not even useful here
at all
ooh yeah I don't even use the Baptist
search around
ah no God you [ __ ] all right just like I
never feel comfortable because he keeps
coming out of like doors and walls
honking DeLorean yeah that thing with an
American flag draped red Oh red I should
have kept it oh hold on a second
what big dum-dum that's right pick it up
or check your inventory I got three it's
worth taking one taking one because I
don't know how fast you're gonna be
coming on the way yeah that's my that's
my fear too oh [ __ ] no also oh [ __ ] okay
damn okay I could take remember that
what happens I can take them now and go
back to the same room now it might be
best anything but I do remember
something happening let's take them
let's just go like yeah I doing this
wait wait wait wait wait okay
no first [ __ ] what no no you're good
you're during a few should you use the
crank now so you don't have it on the
way back
I'm tremors that triggers something it
might
[Music]
now just try using it it should be good
just don't go in yet obviously I will
not go it broke
now use the wrench I'm really really
resourceful okay cool it's a door behind
it so you're good yeah you can get rid
of both those for now if you want you
don't need a wrench until you get the
fire hose cool cool cool all right so
let's I can get both of the green herbs
and you think I should go back to the
save room right to get rid of instant
everything the red herbs so the only
like breaks my heart is like before when
we used to do this kind of stuff I was
like yes this is such smart planning but
now with this [ __ ] following me I'm
afraid I'm gonna die and waste all this
time like alright oh come on that's
right you've got a lot of handgun rounds
you're fine just kill him
it's just like hey this could have
happened when you were sprinting away
from a nemesis or something later it's
happening now you're good
[ __ ] I at this point now you're good
alright so that at least that won't
happen later oh my god you're gonna go
the save reminds I'll take the book to
from his oh no I don't think I have room
if I take those herbs but I could not
take the herbs and I could take the book
instead 101 book no I don't think it
matters
just take the herbs just [ __ ] no I have
enough herbs I should I think what's
because you're gonna have to take the
book no matter what and also you're
gonna come back here with something
later exactly it was but I'll take I'll
take the book I have a reason for this
okay the thing is is there might be
times when I'll be like damn it I don't
want to have a book on me I am always
happy to have a player you could just
combine a red and a green plane right
now I would take that yeah that's much
smarter than what I just said God that
was smart
that's why your coach [ __ ] should I
combine these two um so that's the thing
because you are something to be with
blue right well I'm pretty sure you can
do red green blue in this game all in
one and I'm not positive and I would
just wait until you absolutely need to
find out so see if I'm wrong it out I
think I'm right I personally know
there's one and I'd like to talk through
this with you but I'd actually really
like to kill these zombies in this
hallway too and my reasoning for it is
I've been using the same room a lot and
if I'm almost dead and I'm running from
a dude I don't want to deal with this
well you've started already so yeah I
agree
just going well I was trying to explain
it because I wanted you be along the
ride with me but it's become kind of
more of like I'm making this call I just
feel very strongly you're just creating
more crimson heads really no there's no
comment
how do you know that I just like feel it
in my bones I can feel it my plums Mike
you think I don't have lady plums okay
they're just in my body
we have plums - like don't ya huh
they're called ovaries they're like lady
plums
oh you're going really into the anatomy
yeah lady plums alright I mean really
neat anatomy everyone knows what male
plums are I was talking about your
consistent kidneys okay look closet rent
you don't need right now until you get
the this you should I don't think you
need red and green Arabs Anna's first
day it's wheeze sweet should I keep my
shotgun yeah okay just because of the
close quarters nature's at the car maze
I like be taking some of this that's
fine you've earned it coach that's true
but I appreciate that you're admitting
that this is the last game for a while
in this series that you were gonna need
to like coach cuz for is pretty for
there's a lot of Secrets I know about
I've played that game I know you I've
played through four but I don't remember
neva I don't remember it very well like
I remember like it's you a lot of pesos
I remember like you know it's pretty
easy much easier than these game I'm
like not even speaking very well this
will be aside from my code Veronica
I think this is the hardest resin you're
like seeing the villagers and dealing
with that [ __ ] Matos they're not even
zombies anymore they're like religious
crazed people right like culty people I
mean there's something in like affecting
them it's not like a zombie virus
traditional zombie virus though I feel
like
wait can you go down there you know
you're good you're not okay never mind
touch making sure you want me to check
for her secret do you mean a gas pump
yeah
brevity was not their thing cool door it
up that's pretty close
okay so just let me get a layout here
look at that fresh pal
Shaun White action on the table oh my
god Trip pal
oh so I looked it up it is random the
powder it's not it has nothing to do
with Wow well then I definitely
shouldn't die cuz strip pals worth a lot
it's 45 I wish I wish they only took up
one space so that's the thing see here's
the thing like it is a trade-off you're
right because if I would have brought me
I can say no mmm two slots and trying to
think what you're getting here you're
definitely getting either the machine
oil or the fuse I'll say I think it's
the oil because we'll see you're you're
saying and I know something else happens
and okay so that [ __ ] comes out me
know get that I don't want to risk what
I don't yeah I don't want to risk this I
do remember why don't I come back here
do that oh okay again I don't want
smiley just take it you're spoiling a
lot what I know it's I know somebody's
gonna come at me no that sounds that's
not what I'm saying other [ __ ] can
happen I'm just I don't want to
explosion I told you I would chime in if
I remember say there's a first nice man
[ __ ] guy no that's not me Carl that's
I'll check over there is it who's that
we go check off all right
so oh there's so much hell [ __ ] it take
it the worst-case scenario you can use
one of them to free up space I mean no I
don't want to use a health don't take
that okay
trust me I'm telling you I will I'm do
you want me to not do that
I'm gonna take that first and then go
check the other room and then do the
look really yes okay okay we're good so
yes and then other room I would rather
discard 15 bullets than a health I get
that but I'm telling you there's a
reason for my method right now and I
don't spoil [ __ ] or like I can Alan I
don't even think there's anything going
on in this room he was just like I need
this oil give me that oil son what if he
was like what if when he saw me he was
like I know you want to ask me out all
the ladies are into my old age and
you're just like why does everyone keep
thinking Liz don't want you that [ __ ]
spot doctory hoodie wrapped around your
waist
that's what's turning everybody yeah
that's that's what's sexy about the
electronic lock painting equipment
printing oh I know you're right
try second guess my reading BAC 0.08
don't you drive
you gotta want to do this lock a little
bit
all right
I think you should want to get one lit
up not all for oddly enough above the a
oh I think uh well we were just in that
room and it said bacd OPA you know I
said BAC oh so we only want to get BAC
lit up then right I think but why is the
a lit up I thought I remember it being
like how do you never say no rusty again
yeah never say that should be right no
I thought you said it was BAC it said
BAC on the board but I don't I think
you'd want just want D okay I don't know
it's there's like a letter that's there
you go it's I think the letter there you
go so you just want to do the bright
letter you just want to get just that
little I don't know what the BAC
specifically was for cuz that was deeper
we I want to get the what lit up the
more illuminated letter you want to get
that light above it lit up just that if
I'm remembering this correct I don't
know what that means
oh so element writer I only want B to be
lit up right now at this step you have
two more steps can I lose this I'm not
positive just try it it's not gonna blow
up or anything yeah I know see you're
good no I hold on Abe a does a be great
so do a and then B okay sorry see a
what CD nice so now maybe this is BAC
that's the last step now is DS lit up
you want D to be lit up yeah you're
literally spelling out what DB D now do
a I think there's our B yeah it should
turn off he was eight oh yeah you're
right oh my god something's happening
I'm out of slots
I'm slot 'less or not not [ __ ] idiot
oh my god okay so just get out of here
back to the statue back to statue I
remember this happening and this is why
I told you to get all that [ __ ] cuz I
didn't you cannot come back into this
room you're right you can't come back
into this room but I didn't want to say
that and they'd be like what can happen
to the gas station that makes it
inaccessible oh this whole place is
gonna blow
it's run that [ __ ] here
he's here he's here I just know it I
love that you're more afraid of that
dude than this [ __ ] gas station
blowing up I yes that look like
Starbucks do you see that yes
nice stars books if I had a coffee place
that's what I would call it stars box
stars in some books sweet okay so good
made good progress no damage I feel you
know we should save mm-hmm you do all
that much I don't want to do this again
no see some [ __ ] you're gonna have to go
to the safe room anyway don't you didn't
really do that much I want to save I
promise you you do not need to save
right now you did not do all that much
see I would normally tell you get the
book for your inventories full we
already got the book oh did we yeah book
Ben got a couple things we could do
right now so are we not going to save
room we should go the same room I'm full
yeah but I don't think you should save
you really did not do that much just
gonna do it again it seems like a long
time you did not even do you would not
have to do a lot again it was just all
inventory like management that were
yelling at me sorry I'm just it's not
cool should I good on supplies actually
oddly enough money is great I'm rolling
a you combine those when you get the
agreement okay so you get them first I
don't have that many bullets that's a
machine oil away for now really I
actually see that you need them all at
the same time or can I delivery I can
deliver them but that's still a while
like that's kind of it's like why
weren't okay here's the thing if we
weren't playing this for this video I
just tell you to do that but like that's
so not entertaining then that leaves it
to me to be the entertaining one while
we watch you bring us that's not gonna
happen right I'm not funny interesting
not even a little I have I have a story
I went over a bridge once all right
all right I'm taking over this I think
it's safe to say you can take a lockpick
okay although it looks more like a
pacman with two long legs crossing one
toe strap trying to be entertaining what
am i doing now I have a book you want me
to get the book take the book with you
yes got the book do I need a wrench do
not need the wrench right now no so we
got the power cable and the case I got
oh my god look at all these power five
powders [ __ ] rolling and look at all
these herbs dude I'm [ __ ] I'm
actually morale is back up yeah I'm just
trying to member the secrets of puzzles
after this I don't want to go back
uptown unless I need to yet so bring the
book I think you if you've wrack your
brains you probably figure out we need
to do the book but I'll guide you there
anyway so there's I feel like I might I
might end up sending us like downtown
and then having to come back to the safe
room so be prepared for that but I think
you just need the book okay should I
take something else for health it's
really I don't want to die I think one
for salesperson I'll bring shotgun
shells I don't have that many you have
have 70 that's actually a lot okay bring
just bring the seven that's fine I can
combine a problem you know seven to the
max isn't it yes but I mean I'm saying I
could combine oh yeah like I could
combine those I don't you know if you
need I'd rather take them I'm not dying
last time I said that I died yeah stop
saying that hey no all right you the
book I'm Dwight Holman I'm trying to
think handgun Emily should be good on
yeah I just do that mmm-hmm I mean know
what time we started this episode at
about 3:30 all right let's go
three in a row has been like rough like
I mean I'm actually for once in my
having values you pull up your map
don't get used to it time to shine map
so actually it's not it's pretty simple
it's pretty close
alright go up that's down that's up
alright nevermind figure it out by
yourself no go down alright go on do you
remember the you're going to the pallet
hallway okay
so going down here going back to the
restaurant alleyway them down run to
here to that yeah no [ __ ] actually no I
can't get in there I don't know we're
doing the book do you member this at all
why I would need a book
I remember the statue yeah is it about
that
remember it's not like place your
knowledge here yeah yeah I'm trying
remember where that is on the map so it
would've looked like
I think it's right yeah I think it's
right there Larry
no that's the pallet hallway that's not
it that's where you farthest better
knowledge here Oh was it here go up
there this little nique cuz it was
really close to this you're totally
right that's it yes so I'm smarter than
you
go back to the restaurant le way smarter
than you
yeah just go that way there's probably
to be zombies in this hallway somewhere
net oh yeah hmm hmm check it out
spaghetti huh yeah I don't know if
you're gonna are you going the right way
yeah oh wait I don't know that was a
restaurant patio very good good stop
talking you think is me me I'm one who
got it right
maybe this whole time you've been my
nemesis I'd be a sick [ __ ] twist I
just stay in this alleyway you're going
straight what's that annoying the
electric stuff in the water that's that
sparking battery thing anything okay
best-case scenario we're just getting at
least worst case scenario will still get
rid of the book straight up like the
worst case scenario is that I lose all
this amazing progress so I don't want to
die other than that I really don't give
a [ __ ] I just want to save before I lose
all the stuff that I've done I've done
so much I'm filled with progress
I think now you can take that thing on
the left I couldn't before and I mean we
were full before but I'm pretty sure
that was locked before compass yeah and
I think you put that back in his hand
Oh in the statue I think see that's why
I was worried about if I'm
misremembering this you're gonna go back
to Sweden I was meant to do something
here I know I get that like why put the
book here I couldn't get the thing
without I think so so that's what I'm
worried about I'm worried I'm
misremembering us at the go back in the
statue and hopefully sure that's I'm
saying if you went all the way down here
you definitely need to put the book
there right where else would go I'm
saying if I lead you back to the statue
it's gonna be annoying if I'm wrong but
it's not that far as far as so much
anxiety fine it's it's not like a matter
of dying it's a matter of it is a matter
of dying it's a huge part in the
decision-making process that I currently
hold right oh my god you don't need to
go that way what are you [ __ ] doing
that's the restaurant freaked out I'm
sorry I got cited wait don't get me mad
I just swear when I'm can I go through
the restaurant or Shady's turn on his
turn I got it
doorman no no he's right there [ __ ]
god I'm [ __ ] good you see that oh my
god come on come on come on come on come
on come on come on music
go straight yeah to the statue right
[ __ ]
dogs I'm not [ __ ] around so here
here's what's good about that I think
the faculty trigger that means you have
the you're going the right way that's
good okay should I run no shotgun them
just [ __ ] go for it it's up to you
obviously I think they're in front of
you Neela please heal okay first a spray
those two already like pretty much dead
[Music]
I can't believe I got juked by a dog a
dog I'm the Joker I am the one who Jukes
they've joke the Joker has become the
Jew key the Jew so again I think that
means you have the right item but that
also probably means that that [ __ ]
gonna come after me no that doesn't
usually happen until you you would know
he's nothing just randomly come after
you he has to it has to start with a
live choice event those are hiding the
basement or in the kitchen go in the
basement or hide in the kitchen in there
cetera okay so please dear God just what
just work
that's open I listen why sweet why was
their battery I don't know secret
location that's the thing with all these
games like who designed these puzzles in
the real like it was first it was
[ __ ] Jack Trevor I mean there was
like I'm going to hide this battery
justified it with Oswald Spencer and
Jack I think it's Jack Trevor the
architect of Spencer mansion being
paranoid so now the better you could
take the you can go down to the subway
station remember that the hallway with
the pallets there was a elevator up at
the top yes I remember II serve to think
you want to do that before you go to the
fire hose thing I could be wrong about
the stuff boots so far my where are the
pallets go down then you go down to the
substation no no no it's not really you
were just sewing one past this if you
feel better saving now that would make
sense I you could say no and then we
could do this and then you could save
now we still have another like half hour
what do you think I would I wouldn't
blame me for saving I think you have
more ink ribbons than anything I just I
really don't want to do this again
alright yeah you you only got hit once
you understand like my fear here like I
don't want to do those shears the thing
about saving res evil games if you're
playing by yourself it's not about how
much time you've taken it's about how
well you've done in that section but of
course for the show it's tough but you
did well you only got hit once so that's
why I'm saying I'm fine with you shaving
yeah like it calm
it's not about conserving time usually
when you're playing myself what you're
doing speed run or try to go faster like
it's yeah it's like complicated I feel
because I don't want to do this again
for the show
but I also I just feel like I did a good
job and I like want to maintain the good
job now have like 9 save ribbons I think
so I think I'm I'm rocking no 7 still
good
yeah that's a I still I still want to do
it yeah sevens a lot so she's in hard
mode I think I'm a little broken from
the last one honestly why do we why do
we fall down so we can learn to get back
up just song about that from the 90s but
I'm not gonna sing it what do we do when
we fall off the horse sorry Morrie I'm
not a gymnast do I have everything I
need battery for the elevator ah [ __ ]
you need the wrench again I'd rather
bring it no I don't think you need it
don't bring it you got you gotta bring a
health of some sort yes good call good
call did you do you think I need the
lockpick I feel like I'm just constantly
bringing the lockpick everywhere the
door is red but that's for the battery
to bring the substation I'll bring some
drugs yeah also pull up your map really
quick and then look at the substation
the substation had a red and a yellow
door I believe so that's okay that's
just gonna be an event am I going there
yeah unless you want to yeah let's do it
I feel good I feel good I feel good
about this decision
because I don't think you want to go
back uptown yet it's like an intuition
thing like we don't have all the items
why would I go back uptown with two of
the three items well because one of the
items is that way
no no no don't yeah you're good we're on
the right track no I was saying should I
shoot him should I
Juke him I think he doesn't say every
time yeah dum-dum
yeah he's don't spaghetti head spaghetti
shoes hair yeah I saw it arcade shoes I
don't know you know what I just realized
that's a store front door that leads
into an alleyway no matter which way you
go through it yes that's true
[ __ ] the raccoon city planners taking
wasted when they were doing a right
going through it's really not even that
far they just felt like it was far too
long ago you like what kind of it's a
very like sprawling map as opposed to
like I need to hear this that sounds
like dogs possibly either way your
pistol should be good unless it's a
Deimos in that case pull it that sounds
like a dog yeah that's the dog the pad
paw steps
well let me pull up my map so I could go
I could run and go to the left you want
to go straight down right sorry I meant
run and go to the left my left
that's very confused that's your right
that's my left yells left that okay yeah
I am Joe you're you're Mary oh [ __ ] okay
just shotgun - shotgun shells it's fine
the pallets are gone we could yeah
you're good
[ __ ] pallet so here's the thing I
hope they don't jump over you right now
they're gonna jump up you're fine you've
got a red and green here just kill him
[ __ ] him up right now
nice one more oh that guy's almost died
already you're fine push him on to him
it's good nice
don't try to hit him up there I don't
think you can nice okay yeah you might
be cautioned that sweet that one better
than suck it
get on your grades wait Han do that wait
Han yeah all right start Oh that she
wants is another baby
Oh looks like they're leaking Gatorade
yes that's the poison Oh am i poisoned
we should check that how do you know
again we just say poison under condition
that's right would still be a green flat
line not flat line that would be bet
into which it's very it's very clear
up up and it down down in a way oh no
[ __ ] ominous music restart put why
her knees so close together I have to
pee it's just a feminine thing about the
room people do in video games where
they're like she's lucky he has his/her
general outfit and a tire I don't know I
wouldn't know so that's good you know
you don't have anything to that side I
think I might be good with um oh god is
post war unless wait [ __ ] you could wait
and see if there's like three of them
then just shock on their heads off he's
too close good you have a lot of handgun
rounds [ __ ] shotgun everything's changed
Alex Rodriguez do it again to Deanna
that's it shoot up all right they're
both dead yeah yeah yeah double oh
they're not getting up geez yeah pistol
for now I guess until unless you see
another one behind them I didn't really
give you good advice how much ammo to
bring I remember how many do it to be
down here no you didn't buy Helen sweet
he's dead
look at this guy the bottom right sides
it's looking at the right the foreman
told me to use got me fourth inch nails
checks body yeah what if you had 3/4
inch nails on it that would be cool
Tony's arms can fit into that box I'm
sweet that's the joke for the subways
that's all right terrible sick joke cool
I just got a new slot nice I'm slot rich
which is everyone's gold you're such a
slot rich do not enter a metaphor a
metaphor
I could probably Juke her or anything oh
she's killer I'd probably do her it's
just one sure I like could totally Juke
this [ __ ] jus collodion come hit ah
myself one come hit on my own desk [ __ ]
you okay wait a minute check that thing
Jessica check what that Bay red shiny
thing on the wall oh yeah that looks
what you can't do anything with it it
seems weird yes I just kill her
[ __ ] her I don't I feel like this is an
event coming up and if the nemesis comes
god she takes so [ __ ] long to kill
it's like you know her who is she
Jessica we went to middle school
together so bright yeah that seems um
hey let me ask you this is it something
I'm supposed to shoot and it blows up
possibly you may do it it looks like
something I'm meant to shoot to blow up
[Music]
why but never before has that been an
objective it's usually a to kill a group
of zombies if that's what you want to
try trying
there's no confidence that's the what it
is but anyway let's go all right this is
probably gonna be a live event if it's a
Blue Room that's how this has worked in
the past the fuse should be down here or
the fire no fire no damn okay that's
just is there anything else like me
maybe yeah maybe at the edges
peripheries the ancillary corners of
this alleyway it sucks it's just like an
unnecessary [ __ ] room yep well [ __ ]
rooms are pretty necessary
this looks like a puzzle room so nervous
you're gonna have needed something that
you don't have right now
I think about that my whole life
I'm sent at the manual Oh what's down
here that's a second right
yeah it's kind of joking but all right
sweet before you do this puzzle because
the last puzzle you did triggered an
explosion no it didn't what we were
worried that it would yes it did you you
solved the puzzle it got the machine oil
and then walk two feet and then it did
it cutscene where the explosions
happened
oh you're talking about just don't do it
yeah just a rule of thumb check the area
out you got it it's a cool camera if
it's weird that rusty knob won't turn I
know that game okay I actually used to
know a guy named rusty knob soon those
doors won't open until you do this [ __ ]
making charge try their luck know their
fire shutter doors nevermind is manual
so we're doing it got puzzle do we got
we got puzzles to do man be careful not
to let it exceed maximum levels okay
it's done
what dom bees pour through those doors
okay so how do I know what it's all the
power of the right side I would assume
it looks like what it looks like you
have to get that 50 all 50 to the right
side I think okay I think so let's do it
looks like you can reset it first so it
doesn't really matter which I read first
I like read with him that's the problem
is it's hard to know what you want what
did you just press there blue it says
it's blinking all right so red added 15
blue minus 10 but that's times 2 so
maybe blue initially is the default is
-5 reset let's figure this out before we
just do random [ __ ]
that's smart so do red once we already
did it laughs no no I get that that's
not I'm saying but do you do blue ones
no no cuz then tell you how much I want
to figure out what red does before we go
on do red we already did red here I get
that so that added 15 do it again that
added 30s illiterate yes so it
multiplies what it does so blue must
subtract 5 by default you know I mean
but what what do we want to get that to
what number
that's the problem it doesn't [ __ ]
say hey you're an old lying around can
we cancel him who just wanted to get
back to 50 I wonder what's the fruit you
want to try to get back to 50 15 to 25
what is the other door say same thing
hopefully otherwise that gets confusing
[ __ ]
so you know it sucks if one of the rooms
has a lot of items one of the rooms has
like zombies or something is that a
thing I can only do this once that's
what I'm worried about
all right I don't think that would
happen but this game has [ __ ] us over
a lot so 115 to 125 or I'm gonna write
this down just in case so we don't to
reference it again well what was the
other one
115 or 125 oh this is the one you knew
115 to 125 okay for 25 to 35 15 to 25
was 15
so which one would you like to go for do
1525 you like subtracting will be harder
it sounds start with either one go from
there so adding so red will add 30 so
you'll have 75 so what we want to go
down not necessarily because yeah I
would say so that will sup 35 yeah no
but too much now you're now you're too
low should I get 15 fives just reset it
try like blue it would be like red blue
blue blue or blue red blue blue cuz 15
is a lot blue horn so 20 there you go
please dear God
don't be [ __ ] zombies or something
innocuous enough let's try this out I
would check the room before you do the
next one
see oh oh it's the fuse what the [ __ ]
in the other room would you hear that
yes they just busted in is there
anything I need in here yeah it doesn't
look like it just a second power station
[ __ ] hopefully she's done oh [ __ ] okay
I think I'm of this yeah do the next
door or increase electricity up but I'm
pretty positive it's what you want to do
let's riskier I bet you only get one
check try at this I would rather do that
oh but can you still do that second door
I hope no well the emergency exit either
way it would have been yeah if it still
works that's perfect okay so wait hold
on wait so go to the other door again
the voltage number Oh starting the
starting pool just check that door again
the 115 or 125 why
oh no the sign wouldn't have changed to
the power sorry those dumb you're very
dumb I felt like maybe they want you to
do the second or first but I think we're
good
just yeah same thing just figure out you
gotta go 115 or 125 okay here we go
but you don't want to like you know you
could do okay wait red is 15 what's 4
times 15 60 I feel like the last one you
want to be 60 so in order to get to do
blue red blue red no that's me 100 sorry
it was dumb tried anyway red nope sorry
I thought I had it I know I love how it
like excited you got blue red red maybe
I think the blue red red red will do
Sonia wait another 60 will be 130 barely
miss it oh damn it
we're like red blue I don't know dick
around red I feel like okay
I think what about red red blue red sure
nice there go
oh [ __ ]
blockers it's got me something there I
think this is what grenade launcher
right yeah if it's not that right we
gotta get some gunpowder no I know but
like I'm pretty sure the game switches
it so my probably got the Magnum earlier
some people play throughs you get though
maybe depending the difficulty I think
maybe easy mode you get the grenade
launcher first that's it I shouldn't
good thing we did that shouldn't be
greedy
what just a grenade launcher time is it
that might be a good place to end the
episode and then do the fire hose next
time yeah you might be right
you have the power cord the fuse and the
machine oil I'm still gonna do enough to
save again yes my fault you've secured
ribbons left and because I'll miss some
ribbons for saving no I would have saved
through you did a lot okay I think we
needed this episode get us back god I
hope that guy doesn't come though he
hasn't been here in a while there was
just a live event I don't think they
give you another one with him so that's
just the emergency exit Oh
remember that hallway at the top of the
newspaper office that we couldn't get
into you know what that was you can do
the newspaper office or the restaurant
first so in the restaurant the emergency
escape was that tunnel if you've done
the newspaper office first in the
nemesis attack there that would've been
the emergency escape there's no items in
there cuz I'm excited to shoot it okay
alright yeah I would save now that's a
good good progress made
[Music]
oh yeah save room oh you could go to
that save room if you want down here why
I mean it's either one Oh a what's the
next thing you need to do the fire hose
you're going back uptown after this wait
what do you have you have all three
items I remember I'm trying member what
the [ __ ] the point of going to the fire
hoses
Algy to that um need a wrench you can go
to either save room at this point it's
up to you they're both pretty much
equidistant equidistant that sounds like
a toothpaste they're both okay just pick
one I would go to the one closer to the
statue in case I remember that we need
to be a new statute or something because
you're after this you're going uptown
again for the yeah okay so what do you
mean it's like a trolley key maybe you
have all three items to get the engine
running you know what I mean I give the
fuse I always engine running Jesus
Christ you have the machine oil the fuse
and the power cord
whatever missing I don't know the wrench
will open the fire hosting the fire why
fire yeah who knows I don't know that's
I think this is the last episode for
today yeah I don't know if I have it in
me mentally to do anymore like I'm like
pretty shaken [ __ ] just it should be
easy to dodge dodge durango ngati TOA
tqa lqa i don't rehearse it anymore
something japanese anymore
you've lost your second grade I think
you learned cursing your ability to be
fluent just put this [ __ ] in there I'm
almost tempted I'm think I'm gonna have
we should probably get the fuse in the
power cord and the oil and just bring
him up to the trolley this episode yeah
I've been kind of playing nemesis on my
own time but I only got like two hours
in maybe I'll do you wanted oh you mean
next episode yes I'm just it was like
remember the bishop plugs we need to
think this through like I only have six
more I'm not worried about saves you're
fine that's enough there's also like
more ink ribbons coming but good I'm
just saying like rather than when you
actually need the trolley bring all
those items with you when you could be
bringing health I would say we could go
deposit those now and then
back and do the last [ __ ] up town before
you use the trolley Oh before we save no
no next they're safe
next episode anxiety yes again on the
next episodes announcement no not at all
really no feel like we're there I don't
even over halfway comment it's fine you
doing well it's hard mode it's gonna be
harder this will be a sweet victory once
you finish the game if we do we could be
[ __ ] stars Levine have to start over
yeah see you guys next time
yeah my heart my heart palpitations my
my brain and my heart palpitations